[Music]
some drivers are learning that the
fastest way to get from point a to point
b is to go in circles that means using
roundabouts also known as rotaries to
move traffic through major intersections
one midwestern city says roundabouts are
reducing the number of accidents and
cutting its carbon footprint chris van
cleave has the story
indianapolis may be the circle city
but 30 minutes north a community is
really sending drivers for a loop round
and round we go
carmel indiana is home to 142
roundabouts and counting more than any
other city in the u.s something mayor
james brainard says makes the city safer
and greener
is it buggy that were stopped at a light
yes
two cars were going through this
intersection a roundabout would have
moved 30 cars through in the same amount
of time
by 2025 this community of more than a
hundred thousand will be a one stop
light town we don't have to pave over
paradise we can keep our roads more
narrow and and that's better for the
environment it's better for pedestrians
the circular intersections typically
have one or two lanes while they slow
vehicles down the roundabouts actually
flow more traffic allowing carmel to
remove vehicle lanes even as its
population more than quadrupled
i called it a road diet we're able to
add a bike lane add a beautiful median
with trees and flowers down the middle
but we're moving eight percent more
traffic per hour the insurance institute
for highway safety found the switch to
roundabouts cut injury crashes by nearly
half and on busy intersections like
coming off a highway injury crashes
dropped 84 percent while total crashes
plummeted 63 percent as traffic
fatalities continue to rise in the u.s
we really need to be using all of the
tools in our toolbox and roundabouts are
one of those tools that we've seen to be
effective they also create green spaces
allowing for civic art displays this one
was named international roundabout of
the year in 2016 and by eliminating
idling at traffic lights carmel's
roundabouts remove the equivalent of 5
000 cars worth of carbon dioxide while
saving drivers an estimated 14 million
dollars a year in gas says former city
engineer michael mcbride if roundabouts
work so well
why are they not everywhere in the u.s
that's a really great question i still
get asked
why roundabouts you know is that some
kind of caramel gimmick people still
really don't understand
that safety benefit
nationally there are about 7 900
roundabouts new york and virginia now
require they be considered as an
alternative
there is a bit of a learning curve to
the roundabout as you approach the
circle slow down remember to look left
don't forget to yield and when you see
an opening
just go
around here folks say that's
roundabout right
for cbs mornings i'm chris van cleave in
carmel indiana
very smart